you know check it is great at different
moments during our time here we both
thought that tragic Mike over here was
our one true love and now he is marrying
whatever Janet is a special rocks just a
bit strange I'd like to read a poem
Janet my digital queen Janet we can dare
to dream send nude pics of your heart to
me
Jacksonville Jeff was wrong Jason when I
was rebooted and I lost all my knowledge
I was confused and disoriented but you
were always kind to me and according to
the central theme of 231,000 600 songs
movies poems and novels that I research
for these battles in the last 30 seconds
that's what loves all about
does anybody here object to this
marriage of course overruled
Jason hmm do you want me to be your wife
yeah I want you to be my husband tell
you so by the power vested in me by me I
now pronounce us husband and wife we did
it
can I kiss you or will I be electrocuted
only one way to find out go get a girl I
don't know if what I'm gonna say is
gonna hurt or help but screw it
do you know what's really happening
right now you're learning what it's like
to be human all humans are aware of
death
so we're all a little bit sad all the
time that's just the deal
sounds like a crappy deal well yeah it
is but we don't get offered any other
ones and if you try and ignore your
sadness just ends up leaking out of you
anyway I've been there and everybody's
been there so don't fight it and in the
words of a very wise Bed Bath & Beyond
employee I once knew go ahead and cry
all you want but you're gonna have to
pay for that toilet plunger we may not
know exactly which version of ourselves
was technically our best self but you
know what I like who we are right now to
this version of us to the good people
we've all become om2 el unofficial
leader pack a lot of heart and grit into
that diminutive frame like a scrappy
little auto mechanic the nicest thing
you've ever said to me babe and I'll
take it and do Genet the best robot not
a robot girl not a girl and straight-up
hottie I am attractive yes and you
Alyssa could have ever asked for
thanks guys because of the way we were
conceived of and created Janet's don't
typically give speeches oh she's done
she's not gonna give a speech okay cool
oh one more toast to Michael is easily
the best version of himself granted the
bar was low he is a demon but he made a
mistake and admitted he was wrong which
makes him better than 90% of all humans
and you know what it wasn't really
Michaels fault we weren't getting into
the good place anyway I mean look at us
a self-obsessed socialite a ridiculous
giraffe and absurd British aristocrat a
narcissistic attention seeker these old
me yes I was gonna do eight for you and
one for everyone
the point is Michael we forgive you I
mean at least you tried to find a way to
the good place and that's the greatest
thing someone can do just try your best
so we hereby name you an honorary human
and we would like to present you with
this human starter kit car keys so I can
lose them and say has anyone seen my car
keys I went that I can do that you know
that thing will you and band-aids for
your stupid fragile bodies oh look at
this a stress ball with a dumb corporate
logo oh I can't wait to keep finding
this and then almost throw it away and
then think no I'll use it put the pins
on your lapels didn't give me a pin man
I don't have one okay hang on thank you
where's Jenny
no time to wait for a you three go now
now
[Music]
bortles any day now man
hey guess what I just solved the chronic
problem remember the thought experiment
where you're driving the trolley and you
can either plow into a group of people
or turn and hit one person I solved it
it's really great but I don't think
now's the taxi the trolley problem
forces you to choose between two
versions of letting other people die and
the actual solution is very simple
sacrifice yourself what does that mean
you look after the others they need you
step away from the park goodbye no no
[Music]
hey boss what's up good eye Fred my name
is Eleanor shell strap I have all your
crafts thank you
and your wallets oh my goodness thank
you so much
there was nothing did I didn't take your
money I would never even think of doing
that
no no I'm not worried about that ah here
is I started a new job a few months ago
and I got really nervous so my daughter
Carolyn drew this for me to make me feel
better it's my good luck charm
every time I'm stressed at work now I
just have to look at this and I feel
safe a lot of people would have tried so
hard to get this Terry you are a good
person or not they have my daughter
turns out like you when she grows up are
you right no you shut up
sorry it's been a weird day I hate this
and I'm sorry and did I did I say that I
hate this because I hate this you don't
need to apologize for making a huge
sacrifice to save your friends this is
why people love moral philosophy
professors how about this
every time you see me get a stomachache
imagine I'm thinking of you so all the
time exactly
sorry to interrupt I wanted to give both
of you something before we do this think
of it as a going-away present
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't normally cry at movies but that
was pretty good
my girl was hot my guy was too I'm gonna
miss you so much
Eleanor except you won't that's what's
so scary about this whole thing
I'm gonna miss you you're just gonna
think I'm some sexy godlike figure who
you want to hump immediately after
meeting her you know you're deflecting
by making jokes about how hot it's not a
joke I'm a legit snack but I believe in
you I'm not even scared to get rebooted
because I know that you'll be here
taking care of me I wish we had more
time together a long time means nothing
Jeremy bear me baby we'll just get
through this and then you and I can show
out in the dot of the eye forever right
we'll be okay we found each other before
hundreds of times we can do it again
by cheating
you